I'm Troy Polamalu here at the Bleacher
eSport ready to fill my squad of former
great 49ers and Kansas City Chiefs as
you can see we've got a lot of extremely
talented public lean caliber players
it's gonna be very tough for me first of
all I gotta go with Patrick I think he's
got the future to be possibly one of the
greatest quarterbacks ever to play this
game as well as my co-star in head and
shoulders commercials one two I think
that's a bargain right there
now I also believe that defense wins
championships I've got to go with Ronnie
Lott and 14 to great 49er as well man
that's an expensive five now now I kind
of know what these GM's got to deal with
here I also want to go defense here I
think Brian Young is also definitely a
Hall of Fame player as well somebody who
I admired and loved to watch will drop
to 1 Bryant Young I've got $5.00 left
I think tied in with Patrick mahomes
Tony's going to be great
1 2 3 possibly the greatest tide in ever
to play the game now I've got $2 here so
I've got my great safety I got my great
defensive lineman and I'm sorry I got a
I want to go Richard Sherman right now
but I got a great cornerback slash
safety here but I got to go with a great
running back right there Marcus Allen
another Hall of Famer Patrick Mahone's
arguably could be the greatest
quarterback ever to play this game could
prove that this weekend possibly or
maybe in the future but I think he's
already kind of set the foundation for
that defense begins with the safeties
and the defensive linemen those are the
most important positions in my opinion
that make great defense ronnie Lott who
is the greatest safety in my opinion or
defensive back ever to play the game
coming from the University of Southern
California as well Brian Young
somebody who I played against and played
with in Pro Bowls somebody who I admired
and I think is it highly underrated a
player as well tony gonzalez who i've
been able to compete against several
times arguably the greatest height in
ever to play the game and obviously man
you got it three yards and a cloud of
dust
that's why marcus allen is their running
back the running game keeps the defense
off the field and this is why i chose
these five players
hello everybody again I'm Troy Polamalu
I'm here at bleacher report and I just
built my own squad